oder was geht ab max und willkommen zu
diesem video ich dachte mir ich bin
schon den ganzen tag hier drin und
deshalb wollte ich einfach noch mal an
die frische luft gehen aber es wird
schon in der halben stunde oder so
dunkel
deshalb werde ich einfach meine neue
kamera mitnehmen und wir werden ein
kleines kino und video machen wie ich
draußen unterwegs finden in kleinen
spaziergang machen
so
waschbären
anna willecke
so leute ich habe mir ein paar fragen
stellen lassen mit hashtag antwort x max
und ja die welt jetzt beantworten kannst
du einen handstand
nein nicht wirklich ich scheitere immer
kläglich daran aber ich konnte es mal
also ich habe es mal ein paar mal
hintereinander hinbekommen und dann am
nächsten tag nicht mehr ernst du dich
vegetarisch vegan oder isst du tierische
produkte
ich ernähre mich weder wlan noch
vegetarisch und dem nach essig tierische
produkte
also ich bin weil sowas aber trotz also
ich meine ich mach es selbst nicht
ich habe es aber definitiv vor ich
möchte wenn ich zum beispiel mein abitur
haben allein wohnen möchte ich mal
zumindest als versuch von offroad hier
ein paar tage mal egal bzw vegetarisch
ich glaube eher vegetarisch leben vegan
wäre mir doch nur nummer zu kraft und
doch zur passend zuvor die frage freust
du dich auf den winter ich freue mich
eigentlich auf den winter ich mag winter
nur einzige sache die ich finde es wie
gesagt dass die sonne so früh runter
geht das kann die absolut gar nicht
leine eine sehr häufig gefragte frage
möchtest du mal andere spiele zocken
grundsätzlich ja nur irgendwie bin ich
ja nicht so wirklich mutig ich wollte
mal dieses belohnt tower defense fünf
zacken humans allerdings
irgendwie kann ich finde ich kann ich
das nicht so gut kommentieren wie
minecraft bei minecraft nein ich bin
nicht der beste kommentator aber da kann
ich da kenne mich wenigstens aus aber so
bei so einem neuen spiel irgendwie weiß
ich bin mir voll unsicher keine ahnung
ob ich das viele richter vielleicht
bisschen dumm bin oder was auch immer
aber keine ahnung irgendwie eine sache
habe ich ganz vergessen ich hatte euch
ja letztes mal eine video angekündigt
dass ich was cooles zugeschickt bekommen
habe und ihr dürft einmal raten ich
trage ist bereits was ist jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben was nichts
geschenkt bekommen ich habe bei der
daten hatte sind diese schule ihr fragt
euch vielleicht was ist daran besonders
warum ist das cool aber ich werd ich
muss mir mal kurz irgendwo hinsetzen
oder so ich hab mich jetzt einfach mal
hingesetzt habe ich das hier machen kann
aber freunde da sind keine normalen
schule sondern ihr seht hier sind solche
klappen dran und man kann ihnen diese
schuhe einfach rollen rein machen das
ist so cool ich weiß nicht die schule
gibt es schon länger hier liefen
übrigens die guten stücke und ich hab
mich zu beschicken kommen und die haben
nur ein jahr bis zum vater von ich habe
gesagt ja unbedingt weil früher als ich
jünger war als ich so in der sechsten
klasse war oder so hatten viele die
schuhe aber ich hatte nie ein paar
wirklich zugeschickten kommt werde
probieren mit ihnen zu fahren ist schon
mal richtig lustig es hört sich an als
hätte ich so hohe schuhe an wenn ich mit
den teilen da drin laufe aber ich werde
erst mal vor schulstraße geben gab ich
stelle aber die kamera erst mal ab mich
dass du mir runter fällt oder so ich
werde jetzt meine ersten meter auf diese
gefahren und bleibt eine sache noch mal
macht das so man muss irgendwie die
schule so ausbalancieren heißt beide
irgendwie so mittig und frisch ist lässt
sich leicht
ich werde das heute noch
ich weiß heute noch hinkriegen dass sie
mit den teilen fahre jetzt gesehen
freunde ich bin das erste mal gefahren
ich werde ein bisschen weiter üben bevor
ich die kamera in die hand nehmen aber
es ist richtig lustig
es macht spaß ich werde probieren ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen geübt der
zwischenzeit ihr habt nicht alles
gesehen das ging leider nicht so schnell
wie es jetzt aussehe schließt drauf
hatte aber einigermaßen glücklich hat
immer war einigermaßen kann ich sehr
schön und ich werde es probieren
keine frage beim vielen heißt es glaube
ich zu beantworten es mal geschafft 0
jump fans in jump league zu schaffen
nein kakao kaffee oder tee kaffee es war
viel spaß ich bin links zu den schulen
auch mal und die beschreibung dann
könnte die aus tekken wenn ihr das wollt
und auch wenn wir die schule zugeschickt
haben und so das sag ich euch wirklich
es macht spaß
hescheler max was war dein lieblings
schulfach mein lieblings schulfach ist
ich bin in der schule italienisch
beziehungsweise englisch eigentlich
gleichermaßen
ich liebe einfach sprachen und ich liebe
einfach sprachen und deshalb feiere ich
italienisch und englisch weil es so ich
werde jetzt noch mal eben die rollen aus
den schuh draus machen und nach hause
gehen und dann noch einen fragenden
gewitter machen
ok
fragen gewitter was hast hattest du für
lkw's gibt es im wald nicht wie lange
kennst du ja die frage kommt immer
wieder russischen beantwortet habe ich
glaube so circa 67 jahre in einer
fernsehshow hättest wie würdest du sie
nennen die fernsehshow von max hashtag
einfach mal was bist du mit der schule
fertig nein leider noch was willst du
machen wenn youtube von einem auf den
anderen tag weg wäre herstellt antwort
mehrmals wahrscheinlich ganz einfach
andere plattform nutzen die dann relativ
schnell wachsen würden kommen die nicht
wieder große projekte minecraft projekte
gemeint sind ist bisher nichts geplant
aber ich hatte natürlich druck traum was
sagen deine eltern dazu dass die youtube
machst finden sie cool eigentlich weil
ein so ein bisschen hat man ja schon was
geschafft dadurch dass man einigermaßen
großen wobei eventuell auch nicht aber
schon
also doch schon großen channel hat ja so
leute natürlich sagen was das vom
heutigen video
ich hoffe sehr es hat euch gefallen und
wir sehen uns einfach beim nächsten mal
wieder schreibt man ein kommentar wie es
fanden
und ja bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut